welcome back everybody Atlanta rapper
Young Thug appeared in court for the
first time in person on Thursday after
being locked up in May as part of a huge
gang indictment now prosecutors say
Young Thug whose real name is Jeffrey
Williams is one of the founders of young
slime life often known as just YSL
authorities say it is a criminal street
gang that's behind everything from armed
robberies to murders Young Thug's
defense says Young Stoner life is just a
record label now one of the issues that
has come up time and time again during
pre-trial hearings in this case is
whether lyrics and Young Thug's music
can be used against him while an
entertainment attorney that we spoke
with says that is a slippery slope
we have this artistic freedom of
expression and obviously that's
something that the courts have always
tried to preserve and protect and so if
we cannot speak freely if something that
we creatively Express can be used
against us in a court of law then that's
certainly going to silence a lot of
people and in the rap space a lot of the
personas are really based on you know
things that are themes in in rap and one
of those is violence a lot of times so
because of that it's almost
disproportion disproportionately going
to affect a certain community
Brian this isn't the first time that
we've heard about an artist's words
being used in a trial you've seen it
yourself in your work as a defense
attorney absolutely I've litigated this
issue before rap lyrics are used in
criminal cases in a number of ways you
can be prosecuted for the lyrics
themselves the lyrics could be used to
show knowledge of a crime or lack of
mistake when the lyrics happen before
the alleged crime but when lyrics can
also be used as a confession when
they're written after a crime now the
Supreme Court has already ruled that
music is a protected art but there are
exceptions that prosecutors use to get
rap lyrics in in this case Young Thug
the prosecution is using every method of
prosecution to list these lyrics As
potential crimes especially when you
look at the Georgia Rico charges where
Young Thug is charged as the head of the
young slime life gang a subset of the
Bloods he's charged with possession of
guns and distribution of drugs and even
renting a car that was used in a murder
but his indictment is heavily laced with
criminalizing his lyrics and him
appearing on social media criticizing
his attire and statements prosecutors
like this raising issues uh of First
Amendment whether evidence is more
prejudicial or probative and it begs the
question that's only being used for a
certain group of people in a certain
type of music and that's an argument in
itself yeah that's an interesting legal
issue I'm glad you explained it because
you know that's probably going to
progress and we'll probably see other
cases like it too but speaking of this
one let's talk about one of Young Thug's
co-defendants gonna real name Sergio
kitchens while he was released from jail
on Wednesday thanks to a plea deal
Gunner was arrested and charged with one
count of conspiracy to violate the RICO
Act he was sentenced to five years with
one served in prison but that was
commuted to time served the rapper is
accused of being part of the YSL gang by
taking what's called an Alfred plea the
defendant doesn't plead guilty but
instead acknowledges that there's
basically enough evidence to bury him
well during sentencing Ghana made some
pretty stunning admissions
by itself is a music label and a game
and you have personal knowledge that
members or Associates of YSL have
committed crimes and burdens of the game
and do you acknowledge the following
statement I recognize accept and deeply
regret that my talent and music
indirectly further why sell the game to
the detriment of my community why I sell
as a game must again is that your
statement or acknowledgment
and as part of that plea deal the rapper
is required to do 500 hours of community
service with the majority of that's been
speaking to young people about the
dangers of gun gun excuse me gangs and
he's also not allowed to carry a gun in
a statement released after the
sentencing Gunna said quote while I have
agreed to always be truthful I want to
make it perfectly clear that I have not
made any statements have not been
interviewed have not cooperated have not
agreed to testify or be a witness for or
against any party in the case and have
absolutely no intention of being
involved in the trial process in any way
now the plea deal doesn't require gun it
actually does require to come back into
court and testify in the trial against
his alleged co-conspirators but he also
has the right to plead the fifth so
Terry I go back to you on this Gunna
swears that he isn't a snitch but how is
this plea going to affect the other
defendants well if you listen to the
statements that he agreed to in open
court I think he already is quote
unquote a snitch he has basically said
he didn't do anything wrong that he was
in the car but it wasn't he who had all
these drugs it was someone else who was
in the car he's already said Young Thug
was in the car and so he's pointing to
the gang and saying admitting it's a
gang and he's basically pointing to the
other so I know he says he's not going
to testify that's his intent but he has
to get up on that stand he has to
testify and I think he's already made
all of the statements necessary and the
others you know they may just be in more
trouble than they were in the beginning
yeah I'm curious what he'll end up
saying moving over to another A-list
rapper who's making headlines or maybe
more specifically his alleged killer is
talking about Patrick Clark who's still
in a Houston jail despite a newly
reduced Bond as new details surface in
the case Patrick Clark is charged with
murder in the shooting death of rapper
takeoff he was a member of an
atlanta-based group called Migo takeoff
was gunned down in the early hours of
November 1st while at a private party at
a bowling alley with group met group
mate cuevo police say a heated argument
during a quote lucrative dice game was
behind the shooting in a hearing this
week it was revealed that cuevo was
involved in that argument defense
attorneys and prosecutors say cuevo has
not been cooperating last week
authorities released a warrant to search
Clark's vehicle looking for the bullets
that killed takeoff but the gun that
Clark allegedly used doesn't shoot the
bullets in quest